[Music]
19:23 was a very good year for the arts
harold lloyd silent comedy safety last
was a box-office hit the Charleston was
a national dance craze and the novelty
song yes we have no bananas hit number
one for five weeks now after a 95 year
wait these and tens of thousands of
other creative works from 1923 are in
the public domain these works were
supposed to go into the public domain in
1999 but in 1998 Congress had a giant
pause button and extended their
copyrights for 20 years so now finally
in 2019 the conveyor belt is starting
again and these works are entering the
public domain that means these films
books and recordings are now available
for anyone to use adapt or distribute
without permission or fee that includes
early Hollywood films like buster
Keaton's our hospitality
Charlie Chaplin's the pilgrim
and Cecil B DeMille 'he's original
telling of the Ten Commandments on top
of that thousands of pages of music from
giants such as George Gershwin Oscar
Hammerstein and Irving Berlin and even
literary works from writers like Agatha
Christie and Robert Frost you can take
any of these books and make them into a
musical or make them into a short film
community theaters can show these silent
films for free so you can do all these
things without having to worry about a
copyright lawsuit so get to work with
all that cool stuff more Charlie Chaplin